SPEAKER: --simple calculate.
So we're basically just adding
up the numbers from 1 to 5
from both sides.
So how this works is-- we
start with the red LED--
[INAUDIBLE]
So I need to press
the red button.
So let's say each of these
is represented by a number
from 1 to 5.
So let's say I press 3.
So when I press 3 it
stops up at value 3.
Then let's say I'm at
5 then it goes to 8.
So you just add the
two numbers right up.
Then after that, it
just resets again.
Then you just keep
repeating whatever
button you want to press.
So I press 1 and then I
press 2, it goes to 3.
Then after a while it resets.
So it helps you from
adding up from 1 to 5.
1 to 5 plus 1 to 5.
This is loose.
Anyone want to try?
AUDIENCE: --if you can't
do 2 plus 2 in your head.
SPEAKER: You have to
press the red one first.
Once you press the red, then
you press the yellow button,
then it just adds the
numbers up accordingly.
AUDIENCE: Is it just
two numbers to add
or can you keep adding numbers?
SPEAKER: It's only two numbers
because the server only
goes for 180 degrees.
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK.
SPEAKER: Yeah, so you
can't have a full 360 one.
So you have to
connect the server.
So I was thinking about what
can we do with the server?
OK, let's try adding the
numbers, just to make
the server move up and down.
So it's just playing
with what we have.
AUDIENCE: 5--
SPEAKER: Hit red first.
AUDIENCE: Oh, which one first?
SPEAKER: Red first.
AUDIENCE: Red first.
SPEAKER: Red lights up.
AUDIENCE: Wait, that
was 3 plus 4 that's 9.
Wait, no, 7.